there are certain things that are not
gonna make it out of corona the same
okay anything that was already greatly
affected is now gone right like movie
theaters are not gonna make it out of
Corona no they're done
movie theaters done you might have
certain movie theaters I know some of
you guys are saying right now you're
like like what are you talking about
like old people still go to movies no
they don't and the ones that do corona
probably pick scare them
sad but true okay the rest of us have a
much better movie watching system in our
homes okay watching a movie in your home
is way better than watching in the
theater we all have the elite sound
systems now what I say oh yes I know
there are people that don't but I'm
talking about first world America we all
have great sound systems okay we have 4k
HD TVs in our home sort of you guys are
watching this right now on a 4k HD TV
okay on an immaculate sound system an
incredible couch
you have your refrigerator there so
you'll have to spend $20 on [ __ ]
popcorn and Pepsi okay you have whatever
you want to eat while you watch this
movie if you will have to get dressed
you have to put on sneakers a jacket
pants underwear socks and then go get
bed bugs in an AMC there is no way once
movie companies agree to put their
movies out on some sort of pay platform
that we will we will continue going to
the movies it just won't happen maybe
you'll see you know how like bars do
pay-per-view fight events yeah right I
think there's a possibility you could
see some places do a pay-per-view watch
event for a film right like let's say
Game of Thrones did a movie they won't
but hypothetically speaking Game of
Thrones is moving right maybe you'll see
event spaces go hey we're gonna watch
Game of Thrones if you want to come down
with all your friends will watch it
we've got an amazing sound system we'll
be able to give you drinks this that the
other and it'll become like a night of
it you saw this happen with what's
happening with Game of Thrones right I
think you could see that happen but the
days where there is a movie complex that
was a block long with like 10 different
theaters inside of it playing all these
movies [ __ ] done why
making me get dressed when I don't have
to get dressed why are you making me
uncomfortable why is there someone in
front of me talking during the movie
right why is something economy going to
the bathroom [ __ ] up the seat you'd
have to do a nun that [ __ ] at home all
the things with pre-existing conditions
economically I think are gonna be [ __ ]
by Corona and health care is another one
so the problem with the movie theater
situation if they bring it to online
yeah it's gonna get pirated immediately
yes moment it comes out huh nope is that
right but I think they're hedge is that
so many more people will be able to
watch it and purchase it that they're
okay with the amount that are gonna
pirate and I still think the amount of
people that watch pirated [ __ ] is very
low right granted we might get you know
more comfortable with what is the Pirate
Bay or whatever things like download
sites are but the realities if you keep
the ticket price reasonably low Oh
ticket prices are gonna go way down too
right now they're offering twenty dollar
movies so twenty Allah moves is [ __ ]
up and this is why their price gouging
right because AMC and maybe it's AMC
offering I'm not sure but AMC and then
the movie company split the cost of the
ticket right I'm not exactly sure the
split may mark you could look that up
right now
but it might be 50/50 who knows what it
is so twenty our ticket is really ten if
you upload it on your own server and
just deliver it to us so you saying you
said I would rather watch you're saying
the people that would rather pay double
the money to go out of their house get
dressed put all this [ __ ] on and get bed
bugs at an AMC when they could spend
half the amount money have all their
friends come over to their house watch
the movie together that's another issue
that they might have is that people
might watch the movie together
you might have five people watch it for
one and then just the ticket price but
here's the thing I literally think
they'll make so much more money by
people willing to take the risk cuz
right now I might not go see the new
Pirates of the Caribbean in the movie
theater yeah because I'm like well is it
good and the reason I need to know if
it's good is because I'm not willing to
take that risk of locking up that
portion of my day to our movie yeah
that's so that's one thing so movies not
you're on the fence of whether or not
you want to see it in now
bull watch it at home yet right I can
see that literally imagine this any of
those stupid award shows the Golden
Globes all that kind of [ __ ] if I could
immediately go watch those movies
digitally they're available the second
after they won an award or a nominated
yeah I know what I'm doing that night I
know what I'm doing the next night okay
but unfortunately I got to go to the
theater to see Jojo rabbit
I'm not going leaving my house is he
Jojo rabbit nah but like my girl was
suggesting last night and the trailer
looked really funny but I would never
leave my house to go see it right so
upward it's a dirt it's good yeah it's
you know tearjerker at the end
tearjerker a little emotional hello
hello some yeah people say I look like
that character my ears I get it my ears
go out thanks guys [ __ ] awkward call
me out word